[موسيقى]
توجد
قمم وأبراج شاهقة فوق
العاصمة التشيكية ،
ومن السهل أن ترى كيف جاءت براغ من خلال
لقبها باسم
مدينة مائة برج ، ووسط
هذه الجمال المعماري التي
تتجه نحو السماء ، هناك
اكتشافات رائعة يجب القيام بها على
الأرض.
الآن
هذه مفاجأة ، حدائق القصر
فقط جاهزة
للخطوات والخطوات
التي تعطي ركبتي وخز أو اثنتين
وهذا المنظر يستحق التسلق
لهذا لم أكن أتوقعه هنا في
واحة براغ الصغيرة الهادئة لأنني آخذ المنظر
يخطر ببالي أن أهل براغ معتادون جيدًا
على المراقبة
والتجسس على كنيسة القديس
نيكولاس التي استخدمها
النازيون لمراقبة المدينة
وعندما تولى الروس زمام الأمور في
الحقبة السوفيتية
أخذوا ببساطة  فوق
المنزل الخاضع للمراقبة ،
يتراجع أيضًا أسفل التلال وهناك
وجود آخر تمت مراقبته في المدينة
هذه المرة لأكثر من 600 عام
حتى خلال هذه الأوقات الوبائية
تتجمع الحشود لمشاهدة ميدي  تقييم
الميكنة لأقدم ساعة فلكية لا تزال تعمل
في العالم براغ
أورلوي لاستخدام اسمها الصحيح ، فهي تحافظ على
تتبع الوقت للسماء وعلى
الدقات
20 ثانية
وتعيين 12 قديسًا كاثوليكيًا في حالة حركة
مع مراعاة السرية أريد الحصول على بعض
المسافة الاجتماعية
وفرصة لإلقاء نظرة على هذه الأعجوبة الهندسية عن
قرب ،
هذا ما تسميه مفتاح
[موسيقى
] بالطبع المزيد من الخطوات
[موسيقى]
الآن هذه
العجلة العديدة التروس
[موسيقى]
ما يحدث ، لا أعرف لماذا أنا
أهمس
ولكن ذلك  يبدو أن هذا هو
الشيء الذي من المفترض أن تفعله
الآن لقد قيل لي إنه يمكنني اللعب
بكل هذه الآلات ،
احصل على كل شيء جاهزًا ،
اعتني بهذه السيارة.
هذا
الغريب
في الكرونوغرافيا الأرجواني
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
أوه